so in a couple a right over here I have
two individuals who have who make
$100,000 each in taxable income the
first thing I want to think about is how
much they would pay if they were taxed
as individuals so let's look at the
individual tax brackets here and get our
calculator to figure out what that would
be so for each of them the first eight
thousand nine hundred and twenty five of
taxable income is going to be taxed at
10% and if we around
that's eight hundred and ninety-three
dollars $893 then the next increment
from eight thousand nine hundred
twenty-five to thirty six thousand two
hundred fifty is going to be taxed at
15% I just I already I pre calculated
what that is that's four thousand ninety
nine dollars rounding a bit 4099 then
the increment up to eighty seven
thousand eight hundred fifty dollars is
going to be taxed at 25 percent and that
gets us to 12 that gives us twelve
thousand nine hundred dollars and then
the increment above eighty seven
thousand eight fifty this is essentially
the bracket they fall into because they
make less than one hundred eighty three
thousand two hundred fifty dollars
that's going to be taxed at 28% so it's
going to be plus 0.28 times the
increment above eighty seven thousand
eight fifty so we have a hundred
thousand of taxable income they have a
right number of zeros they see one so
that's a hundred that's ten thousand
right now that is a hundred thousand yep
a hundred thousand minus eighty seven
thousand eight hundred and fifty eighty
seven thousand eight hundred fifty gets
us to twenty one thousand two hundred
and ninety four dollars now this is what
they would each pay as individuals we're
going to look at them as a couple so as
a couple both of them combined if we
multiply by two both of them are
combined if they were taxed as
individuals or if they never got married
and if they I don't know they just live
together what their combined taxes would
be is forty two thousand five hundred
eighty-eight dollars
so forty two thousand five hundred and
eighty-eight dollars combined if they're
not married now let's think about how
much they would pay as a married couple
where they have two hundred thousand of
combined taxable income now we would
look at the joint file the the filing
jointly married brackets and even if
you're married and you file
as individuals your your brackets are
essentially going to be half of these
brackets right over here so it comes out
economically equivalent especially in
the K or it comes out economically
equivalent if you make the same incomes
and we're going to talk about that a
little bit more but let's look at this
married filing jointly scenario for
couple a let's get the calculator back
out so now we will look at the married
brackets and so the first the first
17850 is going to be taxed at 10% and
you might already notice that at least
these first few brackets are exactly
twice the numbers as these brackets
right over here and the general idea is
that you now have two people so they can
essentially have twice the income before
they fall into another bracket but that
keeps on going until you get to this
point right over here and that's
actually the whole point of this video
to explore whether this results in
married couples paying larger or smaller
taxes let's think about how much this
couples paying so the first seventeen
thousand eight hundred fifty ten percent
that's one thousand seven hundred and
eighty-five dollars then the increment
up to seventy two thousand five hundred
is going to be taxed at 15%
pre-calculated that is eight thousand
one hundred and eighty eight dollars
right over there then the increment up
to one hundred forty six thousand four
hundred is going to be taxed at 25
percent pre-calculated that as eighteen
thousand eighteen thousand four hundred
and seventy five dollars and then oh I I
don't want to have that let me delete
one of these plus signs and then finally
finally we fall into this bracket right
over here it's going to be taxed at 20%
the increment above one hundred forty
six thousand four hundred the increment
above that is going to be taxed at 28%
so it's 28% times two hundred thousand
two hundred one two three
- 146 four hundred and we get combined
taxes of forty-three thousand four
hundred the forty three thousand four
hundred fifty-six forty three thousand
four hundred and fifty-six now what
immediately jumps out at you well first
these are not the same number in
particular when they're married they pay
higher taxes
so this couple that they had a fairly
they have fairly high income and they
both make the same amount they would
have actually paid fewer taxes if they
never got married and if they just filed
as individuals now when they're married
they're paying more taxes and the main
idea is they fall out of this bracket
and this bracket came faster than twice
the rate at which this bracket came when
they were just filing individually and
so they fell into the 28 percent bracket
faster so they had to pay 28% on more of
their combined income they ended up
having a bigger tax bill and so when
people talk about the marriage penalty
this is what they're talking about these
people are essentially paying a tax
because they got married so this is the
marriage this is the marriage penalty
now let's explore if there's always a
marriage penalty if there's always a
case that if by getting married you're
going to pay more in income taxes so
here we have couple B and they have less
equal income they still have a combined
income of $200,000 so if you look at the
married joint find the married filing
jointly they're still going to pay forty
three thousand four hundred fifty six
when they file jointly but let's see how
much they would pay if they if they were
individuals if they never got married
and we combined how much they would have
had to pay so let's get the calculator
back out so first we're going to think
about about the first member of the
couple who makes one hundred eighty
thousand in taxable income so they're
going to pay 10% on the first eight
thousand nine hundred twenty-five so
that's eight hundred and ninety three
and then we can add that to four
thousand ninety nine we've done this
already
four thousand ninety nine to that we
could add twelve thousand nine hundred
twelve thousand nine hundred and then to
that we're going to add twenty eight
percent of the increment the increment
above so where he makes or she makes one
hundred eighty thousand one hundred
eighty one two three minus eighty seven
thousand eight hundred fifty eighty
seven thousand eight hundred and fifty
so that's the increment above eighty
seven thousand eight fifty and we get
this spouse this member of the couple is
going to pay forty-three thousand six
hundred and ninety four now to that
we're going to have to add the amount
that the other member that might pay
so he is going to pay 893 on the first
eight thousand nine hundred twenty-five
so it's going to be 893 plus the 15
percent of the increment above eight
thousand nine hundred twenty-five so
plus 0.15 times twenty thousand one two
three - minus eight thousand nine
hundred and twenty-five gets us to this
member of the couple is going to pay see
two thousand five hundred fifty four in
taxes if we add it to the other member
of the couple so we add that answer plus
forty three thousand six hundred ninety
four that's what the larger earner is
going to have to pay in taxes we get
forty six thousand two hundred forty
eight we'll just round to that forty six
thousand forty six thousand two hundred
and forty eight so here all of a sudden
we see a scenario where we the opposite
thing the higher value is if they don't
get married so in this situation they
actually got they actually got a
marriage benefit they got a marriage
they got a marriage benefit now why did
this happen well the thing that might
have jumped out to you is both of these
people had high incomes and they had
very equal incomes while both of these
people their combined income was the
same but then it was less equal and so
what essentially happened here if this
person filed by themselves on the
individual tax bracket they get they go
up the brackets very very very very
quickly and then this person well
they're not paying much in they're not
they're not they're not paying much in
taxes but this person is paying the bulk
of it by becoming a couple by getting
married as a combined entity and it
pretty much this is the main beneficiary
that one hundred eighty thousand and
taxable income that's most of the two
hundred thousand they're able to move up
the tax brackets a lot slower so they're
not they're getting they're getting
taxed at 28% on a much smaller fraction
of their income they're getting taxed at
twenty five percent on a much smaller
fraction of their income they're getting
taxed at 10% on a larger fraction of the
income then when especially this
individual right over here filed as an
individual so in general if you have a
couple with very high taxable income and
they both make roughly equal they both
have very
I taxable incomes as individuals they
are likely to see a marriage penalty
like we saw in scenario one if you have
a couple where their salaries are very
unequal even if their combined salaries
are quite high you actually might get a
marriage benefit because they move the
through the tax brackets faster now
let's think about couples see and I'll
let you think about a little bit you
have equal you have equal taxable
incomes here so it's kind of like a
couple a but their total taxable income
isn't high in fact if you look at the
married joint file if I the married
filing jointly they fall under this tax
bracket right over here and notice up to
this point all of the tax brackets are
exactly double the individual tax
bracket so it goes exactly twice as slow
so if I guess you can think about as a
fraction of income when you have two
people making the same you're having the
same fraction tax at 20 percent or 15
percent or 25 percent and I encourage
you to do the math here it's just good
practice but you're going to see is that
these people are going to pay the same
taxes so this is going to be the same
whether or not they are married or not
married because they are not making
enough combined income to get the
penalty where the brackets start
accelerating a little bit faster so
anyway hopefully that clarifies things a
little bit